[Music]
the art of weaving has been around since
the stone age
traditional weavers use techniques and
designs that reflect their cultural
origins
today's fashion industry has built on
this tradition to produce fine wool
garments
designers keep a record of the fabrics
they have created over the years
they pin samples and books based on
quality colors and patterns
for their customers to choose from
this is what cashmere goat hair looks
like when it arrives at the wool mill
short fibers called flocks go through a
carting machine
this machine opens up the fibers and
mixes colors together
the carting process removes impurities
and reduces the fibers to a flat layer
[Music]
the machine combs and twists the layer
of fiber in preparation for spinning
[Music]
the spinner separates the layer into
threads and winds each one on bobbins of
over 40 pounds
an operator loads yarn into a dyeing
machine
the entire fiber drying process takes
about two hours for a reel this size
[Music]
uncarded blocks of hair called wool tops
are used to make worsted yarn
a worker feeds the ribbon-like thread
into a blending machine
the blending process merges 12 threads
into one large strip
the machine re-combs and twists the
blended fibers
then spins them into a single strand
[Music]
the coning machine winds the single
thread around a cone
by pulling it through a tensioning
device with a series of spindles
underneath
[Music]
this machine can cone 20 pounds of wool
in about one hour
another spinning machine slowly unwinds
worsted wool bobbins
it accelerates as the threads run
through a tensioning device
and onto spindles even though the
machine processes dozens of bobbins
simultaneously
this process will last several hours
the set of threads that will make up the
woven cloth is called the warp
hundreds of parallel threads wind up on
this roll
called the warping machine these rolls
can stretch several miles long
[Music]
the warp is now ready for weaving this
shuttle loom holds the warp under
tension
while it interweaves the over and under
threads using two sets of weaving
[Music]
needles
this moving part the beater keeps the
fabric under tension as it comes out of
the loom
and onto the cloth beam
[Music]
this rapier loom can weave fabrics four
or five times faster than an automatic
shuttle loom
and about 200 times faster than a hand
operated loom
[Music]
the completed fabric goes to quality
control
a worker performs a visual check looking
for any defects in the fabric
[Music]
if she finds a broken thread she repairs
it by hand
using a sewing needle she replaces the
broken thread with a new one
[Music]
once the fabric passes quality control
it goes through a two hour cleaning
process
then the cloth rolls through a steaming
machine before accumulating at the end
of the production line
[Music]
the finishing process for a woven cloth
can take up to a week
[Music]
designers study the fabrics and choose
arrangements to make a collection
they mark selected patterns with codes
and cut out samples
[Music]
then they make a sample booklet of their
fabrics for customers to choose from
the fabric collection changes twice a
year providing a wide variety of styles
suited to the season
you